One of the things that people are very much confused by in the modern world is
what our tech people meant by Gods.
And that's because whatever the day these were that had the motive force,
that archaic people attributed to the Gods seemed to have disappeared in modern
culture.
Now the young end hypothesis is that's because they turned into psychological
traits fundamentally or motivational forces.
So what the,
what archaic societies would describe as Gods,
we would describe as motivational forces.
So for example,
Venus is a goddess,
the goddess of love,
and we would associate her power with love and sex fundamentally.
And the reason that that's an reasonable association from the archaic standpoint
is because the motive quality that makes up what Venus represents is
transpersonal,
which means it's not limited to one person and it's immortal in that the motive
force that characterizes sexual affiliation exists,
whether or not a single individual exists.
So it's transpersonal has the force of a personality because if you fall in
love,
you're motivated by a certain set of standards and perspectives,
right?
If you're gripped by beauty,
say or if you're gripped by lust that imposes a particular view of the world on
you and impels your action sometimes despite your will and so that would be
equivalent from the archaic perspective to possession and it's clearly the case
that archaic societies who are engaged in warfare for example,
would conduct rituals to ensure that the warriors that made up their societies
were in fact possessed by the correct God.
So it might be Mars for example the Roman God of war so that on the battlefield
they exhibited the proper characteristics of somebody who was in a battle,
right,
rage,
you can think rage,
so possession by the god of war would be equivalent to this possession by state
of rage.
Now it's not quite that simple.
It isn't only that archaic people externalized motive forces and gave them the
status of Daddy's.
What they did was more complex than not.
And I think you can understand that a little bit better if you start to,
if you start to give some thought to the modern behavioral notion of the
stimulus and the stimulus is a very,
very weird concept because the behavior is who weren't interested in taking
apart what was inside the brain would attribute motive force to the stimulus,
right?
They'd say if you present an animal with the stimulus,
he will therefore act.
And that meant that their behaviors were making the presupposition that the
motive power resided in some manner in the stimulus.
Well,
why,
why would they think like that?
Well,
it's an archaic mode of thought in a sense.
You could imagine a child saying,
um,
one of my friends today made me really angry.
Right?
Which means that the child is essentially conflating his or her own internal
emotional state with the proximal stimulus that rise to that state.
And you see complex associations like that taking place with regards to the
apprehension of beauty.
Say,
because beauty is a very,
very complex and difficult to localize phenomena.
If you're very attracted to someone,
are you attracted by them?
Well,
in a sense,
of course you are because they are the art.
But in another sense you're not at all.
Because what's happening is that you're engaged as much in the attraction as
anything that's motivating you from the outside world.
And I think that partly accounts for your sense of foolishness,
especially if the person that you're attracted to doesn't return your
attraction.
I mean,
you know that from your perceptual perspective,
you're attracted and dominated by the object.
But by the same token,
you know entirely that easy as it is to presume it's them and their faults say
pretty much it all has to do with you.
So in the modern world where we've been able to separate out the object and the
motive force of the object,
the day of these have sort of moved inside of us and becomes psychological
forces.
But you can understand if you think about it in this manner that things weren't
so clear prior to the dawn of the empirical age.
That gives you a little bit of background with regards to what the notion of
Daddy meant to archaic societies who still utilize those notions as ex
explanatory terms.